[موسيقى]
وزيره الخارجيه الامريكيه الاثنين ضيفه
على الجزائر لبحث ازمه ماري كما يصل
باماكو ممثل للاتحاد الافريقي لمناقشه خطه
متوقعه لتدخل
[موسيقى]
عسكري
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش من زاويتين هل
تقنع كلينتون الجزائر بالموافقه على تدخل
افريقي عسكري في
مالي وما هي المخاوف والتداعيات من التدخل
العسكري في هذا
البلد السلام
عليكم تصل وزيره الخارجيه الامريكيه هلاري
كلينتون الى الجزائر الاثنين لاجراء
مباحثات يتصدرها التدخل العسكري الافريقي
المرتقب في مالي وخطر تنظيم القاعده في
بلاد المغرب الاسلامي كما يصل باماكو
الاثنين ايضا الجنرال سيكاب كوناتي ممثل
الاتحاد الافريقي في الازمه الماليه
لاجراء محادثات مع القاده العسكريين في
مالي الطريق الى حل استعصى للازمه القائمه
في مالي يمر حتما بعدد من العواصم
الافريقيه الجزائر واحده من بين اهم
قناعه جعلت وزيره الخارجيه الامريكيه
هيلاري كلينتون تزور الجزائر مجددا
الثلاثاء المقبل شهورا قليله بعد زيارتها
الاخيره في شهر فبراير من السنه الجاريه
اسبوعين فقط بعد اخر دوره للحوار
الاستراتيجي بين البلدين احتضنتها واشنطن
في الاجنده محاور هامه من بين ابرزها
البحث عن حل شامل قال البلدان انهما
يريدانه ضامنا للاستقرار ولوحده التراب
المالي بوسعه القضا ضء على سيطره
الاسلاميين الذين لا يخفون انتمائهم
للقاعده على شمال مالي نهايه مارس اذار
الماضي تحول كبير عاشته مالي ما كان له ان
يحدث لولا صراع مزمن خاضته باماكو ضد
متمردي طوارق وانقلاب اطاح بالرئيس المالي
السابق توماني توري ما جعل البلاد مفتوحه
امام انتشار النفوذ القاعدي بات للقاعدين
قاعده في مالي تنشر المخاوف في جوار
البلاد القريب والبعيد خاصه بعد ان اوقعوا
عد من الفرنسيين والجزائريين رهائن لديهم
ليستعمل ورقه تفاوضيه موجعه اربكت واجلت
الى حد كبير خطط التدخل العسكري العاجل
ضدهم تبنى مجلس الامن في الثاني عشر من
تشرين الاول اكتوبر ورقه فرنسيه تحدد 45
يوما سقفا زمنيا لدول غرب افريقيا كي
تتقدم بخطه واضحه للتدخل العسكري في شمال
مالي مع ذلك تدرك باريس وواشنطن ان الامور
ليس بهذه البساطه فتوالت التصريحات من
مسؤولين فيهما اخرهم وزير الدفاع الفرنسي
جون ايف لودري من ان وقت العمل العسكري لم
يحن بعد في تحسب واضح لما قد يقود اليه
العمل العسكري من تداعيات في دول مجاوره
لا تملك مقومات الشراكه في حرب من هذا
الحجم على التنظيمات الاسلاميه المسلحه
اعتبارات القت من الان بلالها القويه على
خطه مرتقبه قيل انها ستقدم في الخامس من
الشهر القادم لدول الاكواس زائد الجزائر
وموريتانيا قبل ان تحال على انظار مجلس
الامن معنا في هذه الحلقه من الجزائر
الدكتور احمد عظيمي استاذ العلوم السياسيه
في جامعه الجزائر معنا من باريس انجيو
تشولي الخبيره في شؤون الصحراء الافريقيه
ومعنا من مقديشو الكاتب الصحفي رياض ولد
احمد الهذ اهلا بضيوفنا جميعا لو بدانا
بالجزائر والدكتور احمد
عظيمي ما التوقعات بالنسبه لهذه الزياره
لكلينتون الى الجزائر فيما يتعلق بموضوع
مالي
تحديدا المتوقع هو ان تعمل الوزيره
الامريكيه على دفع الجزائر الى المشاركه
في القوه الافريقيه التي يتحدثون عنها
الان لانه كان فرنسا عملت مع دول غرب
افريقيا وتمكنت من تجنيد كما يقولون 3000
رجل سيتدخل في شمال مالي لكن اتضح فيما
بعد بان 3000 رجل من غرب افريقيا اذا
تدخلوا في شباب المالي فهذا لا يعني اي
شيء وستكون مقبره لهم لتكون الامور واضحه
بكل صراحه ثم طرح مشكل اخر الصحافه لا
تتكلم عنه والسياسيين وفرنسا لا يتكلمون
عنه وهو مشكل التمويل من س يمول هذه الحرب
وبالتالي فرنسا تعلم وامريكا تعلم بان لا
مفر من مشاركه الجزائر وانه لا يمكن يكون
هناك تدخل عسكري بدون مشاركه الجزائر ولكن
عفوا عندما نتحدث عن الجزائر هل هل نتحدث
عنها كموقف سياسي اكثر منها مشاركه
ميدانيه عمليه في في شمال مالي لا نتكلم
عنها كما هي الفائده من التدخل العسكري
نفسه لان نحن في الجزائر نعلم جيدا بان اي
تدخل عسكري اجنبي في اي بلد فيه مشكله
داخليه لا يمكن ابدا ان يحق اي نجاح وان
شمال مالي سيكون مستنقع تغرق فيه الجيوش
التي ستتدخل في هذه المنطقه لان هذا
التدخل يتطلب جيش قوي يتطلب امكانيات
كبيره جدا والدول الغربيه اليوم لا فرنسا
ولا امريكا بامكانها ان تمول هذه الحرب
لذلك يريدون بالزج بالجزائر الى هذا
المستنقع يستنزفون اموالها وخيراتها ولهذا
السبب يعني تبدو تبدو الجزائر حذره في
التعامل مع هذا الموضوع هنا نسال السيد
الكاتب الصحفي رياض ولد احمد الهادي من من
مقديشو برايك موضوع الجزائر وموافقه
الجزائر حجر الزاويه في اي تدخل عسكري في
مالي كنت لم اسمع الشطر الثاني من سؤالكم
الى هل هل تعتقد سيد سيد بلد احمد الهادي
هل تعتقد بان مشاركه الجزائر حجر زاويه في
اي عمل عسكري في شمال
مالي بالتاكيد الجزائر بنظري الى موقعها
الجيوسياسي وايضا دورها المؤثر في منطقه
الشمال المالي لها ارتباطات مع بعض السكان
المحليين وهي ترتبط مع المطقه الشمال
بحدود واسعه تقدر بالاف الكيلومترات
الجزائر كانت حساسه لدرجه كبيره لاي نوع
من التواجد الفرنسي والغربي بشكل عام في
بمنطقه عند تخوم حدودها الجنوبيه وكانت
تهدد بان تعرقل اي مساع او جهود عسكريه
لنشر قوات او لتدخل عسكري في منطقه شمال
مالي الجزائر هذا التغير وان كان لا يزال
خجولا في موقفها من الرفض القاطع لاي تدخل
عسكري في المنطقه المتاخمه لحدودها والتي
تعتبرها عمقا امنيا واستراتيجيا لها الى
نوع من القبول المشروط بنوع من التدخل
العسكري ومباركته
هذا التحول بالتاكيد سيكون له اهميه كبرى
في دعم الجهود التي لا تزال تتشكل نحو
بناء استراتيجيه لنوع من التدخل العسكري
الافريقي المدعوم غربيا في منطقه شمال الم
هل هل الاجتماع الاخير وهنا عوده الى
الجزائر مع الدكتور احمد عظيمي هل
الاجتماع الاخير لبحث المسائل
الاستراتيجيه بين الولايات المتحده
والجزائر والذي عقد في التاس عشر من هذا
الشهر في
واشنطن مثل
فرصه ثمينه لاقناع الجزائر بمزيد من
الليونه في موضوع مالي هو الاجماع كان حول
الشراكه او حول حوار استراتيجي بين
الجزائر
وامريكا
وكان مخطط له ومقرر من قبل يعني لم يكن من
اجل قضيه مالي لكن لا ندري لان هذه الامور
في الجزائر السياسيين لا يتعرضون لها لا
ندري ان كان موضوع مال قد طرح وان كانت
امريكا قد ضغطت على الجزائر من اجل
المشاركه في اي تدخل عسكري في شمال مالي
لكن مجيء الوزيره الامريكيه خلال الايام
المقبله الى الجزائر يوضح بانها جاءت
لتضغط على الجزائر والمعروف اليوم في
العالم العربي انه لا توجد دوله عربيه
واحده تستطيع ان لا ترضخ او تستطيع ان
تواجه الضغوطات الامريكيه
والخوف هو ان تقبل الجزائر بالمشاركه في
هذا التدخل العسكري الا اذا اذا كان تدخل
من طرف افريقي وبقيا جزائريه وبتمويل دولي
اما ان يكون التمويل من الجزائر والجيش
الجزائري هو الذي يتدخل وبامكانيات
الجزائر فهذا سيضر كثيرا بالجزائر نعم
عندما نتحدث عن عمليه عسكريه تشارك فيها
الجزائر الحقيقه هناك حديث عن المجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا زائد فرنسا
والولايات المتحده في اي عمل عسكري هنا
نسال ضيفتنا من باريس السيده ان جيو تشيلي
هل تعول باريس على هذه الزياره للسيده
كلينتون لتخفيف التحفظات الجزائريه فيما
يتعلق بالعمليه العسكريه في
مالي
بالجئ قات ثنائيه بين باريس والجزائر تجعل
ان الجزائر تفضل المحادثات مع
واشنطن بحيث
ان الجزائر تمثل دوله مهمه في الجزائر بما
فيها ما يتعلق بالموضوع المالي وربما
الامريكيون ينجحون مع الجزائريين افضل من
الفرنسيين وذلك باقناع الجزائر بان تعيد
النظر ب موقفها وهو موقع حتى الساعه لا
يزال حازما بشان رفضهم لاي تدخل عسكري في
مالي بعد السيده كلينتون يفترض ان يزول
الجزائر الرئيس فرانسوا هولاند هل سيستكمل
هذه المهمه التي بداتها ربما السيده
كلينتون يفترض ان يزور الرئيس اولاند
الجزائر هل تعتقدين بانه سيواصل الضغط على
الجزائر بعد المساعي الامريكيه فيما يتعلق
باقناع الجزائر بالمشاركه في عمليه عسكريه
في
مالي ما هو اكيد هو ان هناك كانت زيارات
عديده واتصالات الرسميه منذ وصول هولاند
الى السلطه وبالتاكيد
فمن المتوقع ان ز اولاند فرنسا في نهايه
شهر ديسمبر وهذه الزياره لها علاقه
بالعلاقات الثنائيه بين البلدين وهي علاقه
معقده وهي اقل تعقد واكثر تعقدا من
علاقتها مع الامريكيين ومن الواضح ان
واشنطن تقوم بعمل يتمثل في اقناع الجزائر
في حين ان فرنسا ان اردتم تقوم باداره
الاليات والعمل الدوليه العلاقه مع الدول
الافريقيه الاخرى وبالتالي سيكون هناك نوع
من التعاون الامريكي
الفرنسي
مع يتمثل في توزيع الادوار حيال هذه
الازمه فواشنطن اذا ينظر منها ان تمارس
الضغط على الجزائر واقناعها في حين ان
فرنسا تسعى الى خلق الظرف المناسب ل احراز
والقيام بتدخل عسكري في الاجال المناسبه
وحسب المعايير اتفاقيات التابعه لمجلس
الامن الدولي سيد ولد احمد الهادي هل من
السهل تليين الموقف الجزائري في هذا
الملف تفسير الموقف الجزائري المتعلق
بالحساسيه تجاه تاييد اي تدخل عسكريا
غربيا اتجاه ماليا
ماذا لا يعني اسال هل من هل من السهل ان
يقع تليين الموقف الجزائري فيما يتعلق
بالتد دخل تلينه من قبل واشنطن الان وربما
لاحقا
باريس اعتقد بان الجزائر اعتقد بانه من
المبررات او العوامل التي ربما ادت الى
حدوث هذه المرونه في الموقف الجزائري هو
الطريقه التي يتعامل بها تنظيم التوحيد
والجهاد الذي ظهر قبل سنه من الان
والعدائين المفرطه التي اظهرها هذا
التنظيم الذي يقال يعتقد على نطاق واسع
بانه خارج من رحم تنظيم القاعده ببلاد
المغرب الاسلامي وانشق على التنظيم الذي
كانت الجزائر تعتبر بانها قادره الى حد ما
على اختراقه لكن هذا التنظيم التوحيد
والجهاد اظهر من البدايه عدائه للجزائر
واستهدافها سواء فيما يتعلق بخطف الرعايا
الاسبان في منطقه الرابون العام الماضي
واجراء
عمليات انتحاريه في تمراس الجزائريه واخر
شيء اختطاف الدبلوماسيين الجزائريين في
جاو واعما واعدام الدبلوماسي الجزئ
الجزائري اذا الجزائر استشعرت نوعا من
الخطر في هذا التنظيم الذي بدا يتغول بين
مزدوجتين في منطقه الشمال مالي ويظهر بشكل
مبالغ فيه عداءه واستهدافه للجزائريين حتى
ان الجزائر بدات تتخوف بان ربما هناك بعض
المخابرات الاقليميه او الدوليه التي ربما
تشجع هذا التنظيم على استهداف
الجزائر مباشره بعد اعدام دبلوماسيه اعلنت
الجزائر انها قد تكون مستعده لنقاش توجيه
ضربات دقيقه ومدروسه الى تنظيم القاعده
بلاد المغرب الاسلامي وحركه التوحيد
والجهاد خشيه
تضخمها توسعها هذا العامل ادى الى تبديد
المخاوف الجزائريه السابقه التي كان من
بينها خشيه الجزائر من ان يؤدي اي تدخل
غربي في شمال مالي الى تراجع الجهاديين او
مسلحي تنظيم القاعده وغيره من الجماعات
الاسلاميه الى العمق الجزائري في عمليه
فرار غير منظمه
وبالتالي خلق مواطئ او قواعد جديده داخل
العمق الجزائري وح
ذا وهذا ضيفنا تحديدا من الجزائر قبل قليل
الدكتور احمد عظيمي اشار الى الخوف مما
سماه المستنقع في في مالي بعد الفاصل
سنحاول التطرق الى المخاطر التي يمثلها اي
عمل عسكري في شمال مالي بالنسبه لاستقرار
المنطقه ككل لنا عوده بعد قليل نرجو ان
تبقوا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها زياره وزيره
الخارجيه الامريكيه هيلاري كلينتون الى
الجزائر وهذا الحديث عن عمل عسكري في شمال
مالي سيده ان جيو تشيلي في في باريس برايك
ما هي هي المخاطر الحقيقيه التي يمكن ان
تاتي مع تدخل عسكري في شمال
مالي ان المخاطر من الواضح انها تعني
الدول المعنيه اي دول الميدان وهي تتمثل
بمخاطر تتعلق بزعزع الاستقرار لكن في نفس
الوقت هناك ايضا اراده على الاقل من طرف
دوله مالي والسلطات الانتقاليه في هذا
البلد هذه السلطات التي تحمل مشروع القرار
وتدافع عنه وهي التي وافقت على تدخل عسكري
في مالي هذه السلطات تسعى الى تحرير شمال
البلاد من المجموعات الراديكاليه
والارهابيين هذه هي الخطوه الاولى التي
تسعى الحكومه الماليه الى تحقيقها وتسعى
في هذا السياق الى طلب المساعده من جرانها
ومن المجتمع الدولي من اجل ان تتمكن في
نهايه المطاف من اجاده من ايجاد نوع من
الاستقرار المحلي والوطني وكذلك من اجل ان
تمنع ان ما يحدث في شمال مالي يمكن ايضا
ان يكون له حجم اكبر وان يتطور لينتشر في
الدول الاقليم ويحضرني هنا دوله نج نجار
تحديدا وموريتانيا
اشرت سيده جيوشي الى اراده الماليين معنا
الان من بماكو عبده عبد الله سيدبي نائب
رئيس تجمع المنتخبين عن الشمال وعضو لجنه
الدفاع في البرلمان المالي سيد سيدبي هل
اغلبيه الناس في مالي تؤيد هذا التدخل في
شمال البلاد
عسكريا اغلب الماليين
يدعمون الجهود
الدوليه
[موسيقى]
ذلك الصوت غير مسموع على
الاطلاق لاتمكن من سماع الصوت للاسف للاسف
الشديد اراده الماليين لم تصل الى المترجم
عبر عبر ضيفنا السيد سيدبي سنحاول العوده
اليه من
جديد نرجو ان يتوقف صوت الضيف شكرا لكم
ايه نعود الى ضيفنا في الجزائر اشارتك قبل
قليل الى المستنقع الذي يمكن ان يفتح في
في شمال مالي ما طبيعه هذا
المستنقع لماذا تريد امريكا ولماذا تريد
فرنسا ان يكون هناك تدخل عسكري في شمال
الالي ا
هناك اماكن اخرى هناك ازمات اخرى ا موجوده
في جهات اخرى هناك غزه هناك سوريا اليوم
هناك دول اخرى فيها مشاكل كبيره جدا اكبر
من مشاكل مالي ومع ذلك لم نرى هذه الاراده
وهذا الحماس للتدخل العسكري هناك اناس
يموتون يوميا في غزه ولا احد يتكلم عنهم
الان هناك ناس يموتون اليوم في سوريا ولا
احد يتكلم عن التدخل العسكري اذا لماذا
مالي بالذات نحن نعرف في الجزائر ونعلم
جيدا بان الهدف ليس حل الازمه في مالي ولا
في انما الهدف الاساسي هو تازم هذه الازمه
وخلق بؤره توتر يريدون ان ينتهوا من
افغانستان وياتون الى هنا لان هناك ثروات
معتبره وكبيره جدا في هذه المنطقه وامريكا
تريد ان تضع يدها عليها وفرنسا تريد ذلك
ويريدان ايضا ابعاد الصين وابعاد روسيا من
هذه المنطقه اذا في هذا الوضع ماذا نريد
نحن نحن نعرف ان مالي او الجزائر تعرف ان
حكومه مالي اليوم قابله وتطالب بالتدخل
العسكري وفرنسا تريد هذا وامريكا تريد هذا
والجزائر لا تستطيع ان تمنع هذا لكنها
لديها حق في عدم المشاركه في هذا التدخل
العسكري اذا المستنقع هو انه لدينا 1300 م
حدود مع مالي هذه الحدود كلها ستصبح ملجا
للالاف او عشرات الالاف من الهاربين
والفارين من الحرب التي ستقع وبالتالي
سياتون الى الجزائر ثم ان كل هذه المنطقه
لما تكون هناك حرب فالجار يتاثر بهذه
الحرب وقد يجروك الى المشاركه في هذه
الحرب ثم يطرحون قضيه المتابعه فيما بعد
على اساس ان مجموعات قد تفر الى الجزائر
فتكون متابعه الى اخره هذه كلها مشاكل
يريدون خلقها ونحن الان نتحسس ونشعر بان
الهدف الاساسي ليس مالي الهدف الاساسي هو
توريط الجزائر لانها لديها ثروات ول
احتياط صرف ب 200 مليار دولار في البنوك
الاجنبيه
ولديهم اهداف يريدون تقسيم المنطقه
العربيه لديهم مخططات لذا نحن نشعر بهذا
ونشعر بان الجزائر الان هي اكبر بلد عربي
واكبر بلد افريقي يريدون المساس بامن
واستقرار والجزائر
كوحده موحده الان هذا ما نشعر به ولذلك
فنحن نقول ان التدخل العسكري لا يحل
المشكله الا يعني طالما هو لا يحل المشكله
وربما يسبب في بعض المضاعفات الاخرى نريد
ان نسال سيده انجيو تشيلي في في باريز
واضح ان هناك حذر شديد وحتى تخوفات
واتهامات لفرنسا والولايات المتحده بان
الهدف ليس القضاء على هذه البؤره
الارهابيه كما تسمى هل هناك تقدير في
باريز وواشنطن برايك لهذه المخاوف حول
نوايا فرنسا والولايات المتحده
اولا باد باد نحن لسنا في وضع شبيه
بالحاله الليبيه وبالتالي يجب ان لا نخلط
بين التدخل الذي قادته ناتو في ليبيا مع
ما يحدث حاليا من خلال التفاوض في مالي
فرنسا
وامريكا في نفس الوقت الذي يسعون فيه ال
تقديم المساعده للجيش المالي لقتال ما
يعتبرونه محتلين لارضهم في الشمال هذان
البلدان يجريان عمليات محادثات بين
الطرفين نحن نعرف بان الجزائر هي في ذات
الوقت مصدر المشكله ومصدر الحل فهي فعلا
فاعل ينظر اليه بانه فاعل لا غن عنه
بالنسبه
لفرنسا
ومريكا لكن ايضا الجزائر من ناحيتها يجب
ان تقوم بما عليها وماع من اجل
ان تقوم بدورها وان تعمل ما هو
ضروري لتسهيل الوضع المعقد حاليا وان
تتدخل لدى بعض الفاعلين الذين تعرفهم جيدا
اللاعبين على الميدان من اجل ان تحسن
الوضع على الميدان وكذلك من
اجل ان تؤدي الى مشروع يؤدي الى
الحل والذي يتجاوز المساعده الدوليه
للقوات الماليه نعم سيد ود احمد الهادي في
نهايه البرنامج هذه المخاوف التي اشرنا
اليها في موضوع التدخل العسكري في مالي هل
تعتقد بانها قد تؤخذ بعين الاعتبار من قبل
واشنطن
وباريس اعتقد بان اي عمليه تدخل عسكري
ليكون ناجعا لابد من ان يضع في الاعتبار
جذور المشكله الماليه المشكله الماليه
ليست في سيطره تنظيم القاعده في بلاد
المغرب الاسلامي
والجماعات الموسومه بالارهاب على المنطقه
هناك مشكله تتعلق بهويه السكان المحليين
بمطالبات بنوع من الاستقلال الذاتي ومن
تنميه مناطقهم يعود الى الستينات انفجر في
التسعينات
وقعت اتفاقيات في الجزائر في 92 و90 في
طرابلس من اجل طي ملف الحركات التمرد
الحركات الانفصاليه الماليه اذا اي تدخل
عسكري لتطهير منطقه شمال المالي من
المسلحين اذا لم يكن بنيه ان يرافقه حل
سياسي ينهي ويقتلع المشكله الاسواد من
جذورها التوصل الى حل سياسي ما بين سكان
مناطق الشمال والحكومه الماليه ينهي هذه
المنطقه ويمنع من ان تتحول الى بيئه
ملائمه لنمو وتطور سواء التنظيمات المسلحه
وشبه كات تهريب المخدرات وتهريب السلاح
والجريمه المنظمه وغيرها يكون فعلا التدخل
العسكري لم لم يكن ناج عن ولم يكن ولم يكن
الهدف منه انهاء اللا امن الذي يسود في
المنطقه شكرا لك سيد رياض ولد احمد الهادي
الكاتب الصحفي الموريتاني كنت معنا من
مقديش وشكرا ايضا لضيفنا من باريس انجي
وتشيلي الخبيره في شؤون الصحراء الافريقيه
وشكرا ايضا لضيفنا من الجزائر الدكتور
احمد عظيم استاذ العلوم في جماعه الجزائر
كان بودنا ان يكون الصوت المالي معنا هنا
من خلال السيد عبده عبد الله سيربي لكن
للاسف لم يصل نرجو ان يكون الصوت المالي
واصلا فيما يتعلق بهذه الازمه بشكل عام
دمتم في رعايه الله والى
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
ه